can you have a good meeting where
everything goes right and then the
executives reject your pitch yes you can
and it happens quite a bit actually and
those are for reasons that are
sometimes totally out of your control
um I was mentioning earlier that
sometimes even on our side we're
business to business so we're dealing
directly with presidents of networks or
or heads of channels or VOD platforms
and um
we're in a meeting and we're pitching
and presenting our slate of projects and
then uh unbeknownst to us behind closed
doors in their boardroom
they get a new mandate from the top and
all of a sudden you know metrics come in
or there's some kind of a decision at
the channel to Pivot in terms of content
and we find out about it later and so
the next time we have a meeting it's
either we get rejected on titles that we
were certain were going to happen
um or we just find out that like oh you
know that that direction you were going
all in on is now no longer the case and
now going over here so even at our level
that happens and so I think it's very
important for anyone starting out in the
industry to remember that like
you can pitch something in January and
like nobody wants it and then like July
everyone's looking for that exact same
thing and it's like you know a lot of
that is you're just sort of shooting in
the dark to a degree that's why it's
important to do as much research as you
can find out the the kind of core
consistencies of what companies are
doing the general trends that networks
or VOD platforms are going for the
general buckets of content they focus on
and at least you're like kind of in the
right Zone you will never have all of
the information and so yeah you can go
in you can be on total good terms with
everybody you can you can be presenting
yourself extraordinarily well your story
could be very well received in the room
there could even be some back and forth
in terms of paperwork and then all of a
sudden last second
we're pulling away from this deal it
happens yes and I think developing a
thick skin and just accepting that and
uh being realistic about that is the
only way to battle it and just move on
to the next one and it doesn't the other
thing is critical in that is not to lose
your temper it's to stay well composed
it goes back to the other things
relationships are key uh uh it's a lot
like dating
um it's it's you need to be able in
presentation matters even I guess in
terms of uh principles of pitching like
you need to handle rejection very well
and be professional about it and
understanding if you need to like take a
day before responding that's fine but
you know always respond to it with a I
get it thanks for the opportunity Etc
because then you're keeping that
opportunity alive for the future and
guess what like those companies will
sometimes come back and say we have this
new project can you write it so if you
rejection happens it's part of the game
and can it also happen where you're in
the meeting and you get these arms
crossed and you think oh I have bombs
and I just did a horrible job and then
you hear actually that you're their
person yes this is it absolutely happens
too
um
uh
how do I say this like it's it's when
you focus on genres that are just
um the core needs you know it's uh they
know whether it works or not and like
you know these are people that get
pitched like dozens of projects A Day In
some cases
um I have been in meetings where like
the guy showed up late and like was
clearly it didn't look like he was
paying attention at all and um you're
just sort of like you feel like talking
to someone who's just staring at their
phone like pitching to a teenager and
it's like
um
then all of a sudden you get that email
like a week later and it's like so you
just gotta go with it and you know you
can't control this is what I tell my
kids it's like you can't control what
other people do you just have to focus
on what you are doing and the decisions
you are making how you're presenting
yourself and making sure that you're
bringing up what you can do presenting
yourself and pitching your ideas in the
best way you have the control of doing
and that's not just in the room that's
the that's if you create a website if
you do your personal branding how will
you relax how you relate to people
online the kinds of stuff you type
online that stuff doesn't go away and
you Google enough you'll find that on
people and so it's very critical that at
all times you're conducting yourself in
the best manner you can but yeah it's
like
I've dealt with network Executives who
it's like I felt like they didn't even
remember that we had a meeting and it's
like two weeks later we got a deal so it
happens yes
what are the five most common reasons a
movie idea will be rejected
I think the most obvious one is that it
is just out of sync with what the
company needs
so it's like
if it's just a genre or a style or you
know TV show movie whatever it's like if
if the project itself just does not mesh
with the core basics of what the company
Works Within
they're not gonna
they're not gonna like turn ship for you
you know
um I think a second reason after that is
if your project is too similar
two other things that are in the market
we work a lot with Christmas movies
uh Christmas romances and you would
think that there's like only five or six
versions of the same story you can tell
but the truth is it's infinite there's
always unique Slants you can take but if
it's too similar to something that
already exists in the market or has been
done especially recently that's
something that we'll just take a step
back and say it's not gonna not gonna
jive with us
um
third thing and I think this is where
you as you go deeper into this this is
when it gets a little bit
um I guess more fresh information for
writers who might not have visibility to
some of these more internal workings
so uh I would say a third reason is
when it focuses on subject matter or
interactions of characters
that just don't resonate well on screen
and so what I mean a good example of
that would be like something that is way
too social media heavy and I know like
social media is a I mean you can start
whole relationships in today's world via
app and another means so it's like
that's fine but it doesn't translate
really well on screen and so making sure
that visually from beginning to end this
project is actually going to make sense
that's pretty critical
and then you get to other things that
you know they don't talk about in
screenwriting books and they don't
necessarily pitch in film schools and
that's like what is the budget budget's
critical like if you're writing
something that is out of sync with the
real world value of what the movie is
it's not going to make any sense
so if you're writing
um a basic TV movie but you're writing
it at a budget that is way above that it
doesn't
correlate the company's not going to see
any Merit in it because they're going to
say we're not going to pay all this
money because we know where the metrics
are we know where the clients are in
terms of pricing uh and then if you go a
Step Beyond that I would say
um
I would say it's production related and
what I mean by that is
it's a script that is written in a way
that is not production friendly
uh most of the people who are reading
scripts have a lot of production
experience and they can read the script
and know like right away
at least ballpark this is how much these
things are going to cost whether it's a
TV series whether it's a movie they know
one of the SAG raids they know what are
the crew rates so if you have a script
with like way too many cast members way
too many expensive locations way too
many things that just are complicated to
make happen within the budget level of
what the project you're working on
should be it's going to get rejected but
that's why I kind of put it in that
category which is it's hard for writers
to know what those numbers are in the
book I wrote uh mastering the pitch in
each section of the book I kind of
devote a chapter to
um like movies and then TV shows and
reality TV shows and all that and I
actually put in there what are the
budgets supposed to be so we put those
in so you kind of get a sense of like
you know a high end of this would be X
dollars a mid-level would be this many
dollars and a low budget
professional not like micro budget
shoestring budget but like one that
could actually be on TV or like an
original for a VOD platform what would
that low budget look like so if you can
write at that budget level at a
production that makes sense for like 12
to 20 days of production you're starting
to kind of remove some of those layers
and then I would say I'd add a six to
that and that's just if the writer's an
if they're just complicated to
deal with
could be a good script and you'll just
pass on it what would a a low low budget
let's say film Christmas movie shot in
another state and let sorry not
California maybe it's one that has tax
incentives B what would the budget for a
low budget uh so they scale
um
and we don't shoot any of them in LA
because La is extraordinarily expensive
to film and we shoot and and we don't
necessarily even shoot in the states we
do a lot in Canada and we do a lot in
Australia but and we do work a lot in
tax efficient States
um George is a great tax efficient state
but Netflix does so much there that you
know it's it's it's becoming a lot more
expensive to shoot there but there's a
lot of places we just shot a movie in
Kentucky we shoot a lot of places but uh
the general budgets are going to be
one million ish to two and a half
million
um but that is like total gross cost
that is like how much cash is required
to shoot the movie but the way we work
is that we are being quite
financially Savvy in terms of how we
structure deals how payments are paid
out how we classify things and then if
we work in a tax efficient States and we
work within very specific parameters and
we Source Talent and crew and utilize
local resources we can get what we call
soft monies or tax rebates like the idea
of soft monies is um that there's
incentive for us shooting these movies
in some of these different areas whether
it's like local municipalities or local
States Etc they want the business and so
they're willing to sort of uh really
make it worth our while to shoot there
instead of other places
so on our side of the business we're
looking for those opportunities you know
we know our scale of how much this stuff
needs to cost we know where we can shoot
it and how we can shoot it we also know
well how many characters do we need in
the movie so that we don't exceed our
budget how many locations do we need in
there so we don't exceed our budget
because you start doing company moves
that gets pretty pricey so it's it's a
combination of being able to maximize
soft monies tax rebates pre-sales when
they're possible license fees from a
client and a script that meshes with all
of that so if it's a screenplay that's
not fitting into that model it's it's
not really usable for us